In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinak Sadion for April 28, on which we commemorate our Holy Father's
Cyril, Bishop of Tudov.
Born into a wealthy family in Tudov, in the Minsk region, Saint Cyril showed however no
predilection for riches and glory.
After having spent his childhood studying the scriptures with Russian and Greek masters,
he entered the monastery of St. Boris and Gleb.
Having been clothed in the Holy Angelic habit, he exhausted his body in prayer, vigils,
and the service of the brethren, and became a model of perfect monastic observance to the
other monks.
He encouraged them by fraternal exhortations on humble submission.
Her salvation is not for the monk who does not obey his abbot in all things.
Later, aspiring to higher labors, he lived on a pillar following the example of the stylites
of older times.
This extraordinary eschese and his spiritual writings contributed to the spread of his reputation
throughout the country, and resulted in the people's unanimous insistence that he accept
the office of Bishop of Tudov.
All the labor that he had, till then, invested in eschese, he thens forward used for the
spiritual upbuilding of his people.
He gave many homilies on the feasts during the year, and also teaching, taken from the gospel
and the Old Testament.
These oratorical works bear witness to the perfect knowledge of the Holy Scriptures and the
fathers of the church that the saint had acquired during his solitary days.
Being a stay in the monastery of St. Nicholas, he wrote an anthology of prayers imprinted
with the spirit of repentance, not unlike those of St. Ephraim III.
In imitation of St. Andrew of Crete, he also composed a great canon of repentance to the Lord,
and a canon to the Holy Spirit.
At the end of a life spent in labors for the upbuilding of the body of Christ, St. Cyril
venerated in Russia as a second Christ-system, entered into rest in peace in the year 1183,
sometime after having been relieved of his duties in order to refine his monastic isihia.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.